[Music]
John schaffner designed the most famous
New York City apartment of all time
except it only had three walls and no
ceiling and it wasn't actually in New
York john shafte designed a set of
friends
John is a production designer and John
has worked on a lot of show I've done 44
series and sixty eight pilots Darmon
Greg the drew Carey Show Two and a Half
Men Big Bang Theory and most notably
friends
if when I get assigned a new show I do
what is called a sketch model in white
paper and you hold it up and you close
one eye and you squint and you can see
just what the camera is gonna see when
we were presenting friends I presented a
white model and the producer looked at
it and said well now what are we gonna
do about color what do you want to do
and I said I think we should paint the
sad purple everybody was really anxious
about nobody likes change until I
painted the little model purple color is
really important in terms of
establishing the show identity when you
switch to friends you saw that it was
purple and you stay tuned
one of the responsibilities of a
production designer is to look into the
future if you can we put a door all the
way up this hallway and we really didn't
say where it went to I said why don't we
just wait and see where the story is
taken so all of a sudden years into the
show we've never seen this door open
they do an entire episode about this was
Monica's messy closet oh my god
I definitely think that the coffeehouse
on friends sort of influence our culture
where people like to meet and hang
around thank you and now of course 25
years later there's the coffee house on
every corner and I'm surprised how many
of them have overstuffed chairs in the
pilot at the moment when Rachel walks
through the door and the wedding dress
is a pivotal moment we made a decision
to put the door up here on a diagonal
she bucks POW through those doors and
straight to the camera and everybody had
to like physically turn and look this is
everybody this is Chandler and Phoebe
and Joey and you remember my brother
Ross sure who knew that that was gonna
be the beginning of 10 years of a number
one show on television audiences relate
to sitcoms because once you get to know
the characters you become invested in
their story so it's easy to turn on and
watch an episode of friends it's a
comfort coming back to visit with these
characters and be with them for that
half-hour I'm so lucky I got to design
friends
when I was a kid I always played with
Legos I built cars planes motorbikes now
I built an arm
[Music]
meet David Aguilar my name is David
Aguilar I am from Andorra and I'm 18
years old when David was born his right
arm hadn't fully developed this is the
my right arm growing up it was quite
annoying because I received a lot of
commentaries like oh you don't have a
hand or something like that and while
some would see this as a disadvantage
David is just a regular kid he likes EDM
he goes by the name hand solo get it he
has an embarrassing dad he goes to
school this is my school and he can open
doors with his Lego arm so cool growing
up he was obsessed with Lego so much so
he wanted to make it a part of him
literally I build my first prosthetic
arm when I was 9 years old and I build
it I run my hand it started and being a
boat unfortunately the Lego bricks
weren't strong enough and it wasn't for
another nine years - he would try again
this is mk1 this is LEGO Technic it's
like the sophisticated part of Lego I
can do push-ups with this thing so it's
quite strong when I first build the arm
and it was fully functional I went to
the mirror and I was like oh that model
the mk1 only took five days to build of
course like any good adventure he got
straight to work on an upgrade and this
is mk2 it has a battery that works like
a biceps and it has this fishing cable
that ties up in here when I fix this to
my shoulder I can do this and the arm
closes I can stop in the middle and move
it by myself
when I first brought this they were all
really amazed because how can somebody
create a hand out of Legos I was a
normal guy and when I build a yarn
everyone was like you're awesome you're
you're really smart they told me they
are really proud to be to be my friends
it's amazing
[Music]
party is just an illustration but we
were written because finish the passion
original report a question arose a
capitalist economy in Hazzard Sylvia
cool you have to check to straighten his
vision as mentioned something about
mother the conquer deep in the suburbs
of Moscow in a town called Nova selkie
Sergei and his comrades tirelessly work
on a pretty unique hobby
through years of experimenting and
prototyping they've taught themselves
how to build life-size tanks out of a
garage all in the name of celebrating
Russian history muscles - Lanka Pakistan
yeah mi soo my little beauty networks
are here it is an easy movie Balu spent
on a chili admitted to village in
Jeremiah ran a solution seriously
daughter in the cotillion especially why
you could not anxious for him taking
presumably pardon
[Music]
we as officials live cattle someday
thank a conservative cellphone on spoon
get a system for news updates
nope rebellion foolish to deal with a
boutique irritating Andronicus dyspnea
chronically storybook usually most with
period to which mr. penis producer you
must forgive ms ideal Deborah service be
seen in the tank stay busy metropolis
machinima Boise panzerkampfwagen again
just as one of the machine with each
contact is when consolidated as if years
McConnell a description of the diesel
10's my histogram McAllister skeptical
cultural very discouraged not as mr.
Wallach good a person as a human human
cumulative because I'd bounce to Chicago
good shortens to do stunts in style
design is
[Music]
can you smell is innocent under
international wired Muslim because I
assumed it included Anita mushroom Naga
Naga become another candidate meets them
the probability of vehicle agriculture
business machinery Jerry's fault Jerry's
the most technically at the Dublin
repair and through paternity screencast
box wars really feels like a medieval
battle the only difference is this with
cardboard
[Music]
there's rules to box wars but they're
very limited there's no winners we like
to say that if you're in a box Wars
where you've already lost I'm Ross I'm
one of the supreme overlords of box Wars
box Wars is a collective of people that
love to get together create cardboard
creations and then destroy them in an
epic battle it's more about
competitiveness in being creative the
only materials that you can use
cardboard adhesives like tape hot glue
whatever you can find in packaging
that's the stuff that we like to use to
build our suits every single battle has
a new engineering challenge like
building a giant aircraft carrier or
building a monster truck that actually
rolls or a train which has to carry in a
whole bunch of policemen we encourage
people to come down to our events and
build as elaborate costumes as they can
possibly make once they've build the
props then we all gather at a park and
then we battle everyone comes in and
clashes and destroys everything
stuff that we spent weeks on designing
it's all gone in seconds it just started
off really small but then all the sudden
it blew up there's generally around
about 50 to 100 people in the actual
battle and then it can be hundreds and
hundreds of spectators
we've got chapters that have started up
all around the world we've had groups in
Japan in Europe in America in Canada it
seems so
childish but it's fantastic that a
concept like this crosses cultural and
language barriers Vauxhall's is based
around comedy that's the whole point of
box wars we're losers what we're doing
is quite pathetic we shall have real
jobs but here we are building stuff out
of cardboard if you laugh at us that's
exactly what we want
[Music]